[Music]
Yesterday I first expressed my solidarity and
demanded the extraordinary work that
the state security forces and bodies are doing in our country,
some of them
civil guards who were injured as a
result of this violent assault and
I also want to return to  repeating that
description violent and organized
by mafias that traffic in human beings
to a city that is a Spanish territory,
therefore it was an attack on the
territorial integrity of our country
in a violent way
[Music]
las aguas
freestyle y el mundo government software
on spain show
and externalizations gration
constellation brands and and life
stipulate relations
[Music]